- [Narrator] Empty
shelves at supermarkets,
the rationing of staples
and shuttered stores.
After more than a month
of fighting in Ukraine,
ordinary Russians have fewer
options when they go shopping.
More than 600 foreign brands
have announced their withdrawal
from Russia according to Yale University.
Some sided concerns about
the conflict and the safety
of staff while others left
as a U.S. and its allies
unleashed a raft of sanctions
that could complicate
business operations in the country.
- Russia has been decoupled
from the global economy
and all these goods and
services that came into Russia
over the past years
and made Russia part of the modern world.
So the ripple effects of
this are going to be massive.
- [Narrator] So here's
how people in Russia
are dealing with the economic
fallout and the glimpse
it offers into public
sentiment about the war
across the border.
In the 1990s, as the
former Soviet Union began
disintegrating, foreign
brands started setting up shop
and many were immediately popular.
Fast forward about 30
years and with the war
across the border,
hundreds of these companies
are temporarily curtailing operations
or pulling out entirely from Russia.
That's partly because running a business
under Western sanctions
is getting difficult.
For instance, several Russian
banks have been delisted
from the global financial messaging system
and that can make it trickier
to carry out basic tasks
like importing supplies
or paying employees.
Many of these brands
are beloved by Russians.
On the day, IKEA announced
that it was shutting
its 17 stores, there were
long lines of people waiting
to do their last minute shopping.
The Swedish company's pullback
has also meant that jobs
are in limbo, even though
it said it would support
15,000 employees in the immediate future.
(man speaking foreign language)
- So far, most of the
companies that are pulling out
have said that they will
continue paying their employees.
It's not quite clear how
long they'll be able to last,
so it's still sort of a
wait and see approach.
- [Narrator] Not all foreign
companies have chosen to leave.
Some are playing a balancing act
by staying put and scaling back.
For instance, McDonald's
said it's suspended
direct operations in
Russia but the outlets
owned by local franchises
have remained open.
And Pepsi said, it's halting
sales of its big soda brands
but will continue to sell other products
like the milk and baby food.
The corporate pullback is
one of many pressure points
on Russia's economy.
A few days before Putin launched the war,
western nations dropped
hard hitting sanctions
on the country.
And as a Rubble plunged,
Russians lined up at ATMs
to take out cash.
This was also compounded by inflation
which has been persistently on the rise
during the coronavirus pandemic.
And now the war has made
the purchasing power
of ordinary Russians even weaker.
So some started stocking up
which has prompted supermarkets
to restrict the sale of some products.
Putin has vowed to carry out
a raft of measures to offset
the pain of sanctions on Russians
and the government reassured the public
that there will be no shortage
of food or daily necessities.
But as Western sanctions
shake the Russian economy
and foreign companies
continue to scale back,
domestic support for Moscow
and the war isn't waning.
- That even among people
that are against the war,
there's been sort of a
blow back of thinking
how are these actual penalties,
how are Western companies
leaving really helping fix
the situation?
- [Narrator] And this anti-west
sentiment is already strong
in large swaths of the country.
For example, in one town
more than 150 miles away
from Moscow, protestors drove
cars marked with the letter Z
which has become a Russian pro-war symbol.
- Most of rural Russian
and provincial Russia,
they rely on Russian
produced goods anyways
and this is the majority of
Vladimir Putin's support.
- [Narrator] And Putin's
popularity has increased
after Russia launched its war in Ukraine.
He had an 83% approval rating according
to the independent Russian
pollster Lavada Center.
So with no immediate
end to the war in sight,
ordinary Russians may deal
with deeper economic pain
as sanctions mount and more
companies choose to leave.
(soft upbeat music)